I’ve always hated shopping for furniture.
Grocery shopping?
They’ve got cake, cheese, and beer.
Sounds perfect to me.
Clothes shopping?
Sure, I’ll pick up some new jeans, that’s
a fine Saturday afternoon.
But shopping for household items, pushing
through the crowds of broke college students
and bickering couples on a hunt for coffee
tables and tv stands, all 20-page instruction
books, a dozen wooden puzzle pieces, and tiny
little screws that disappear into your carpet
the second you take them out of the package…that’s
my own personal hell.
So, when my wife Brenda, the love of my life,
my light in the darkest of times, asked me
to go to Ikea with her to pick up the GLOSTAD
sofa she found online, plus a few other essentials
for the new house, I was reluctant, to say
the least.
But love won out, and I just couldn’t say
no to those eyes - or the promise that we’d
pick up my favorite takeout on the way home.
It would be a quick trip.
We run in, we grab the sofa and maybe a HYLLIS
shelving unit for her office, and we head
back out.
One hour total, tops.
Well, some mad god of chaos and cheap furniture
must have turned his hateful eye on me, because
it’s been over a day and I’m still here.
I’ve been walking for hours, and nothing
has changed.
I knew Ikea was big, but this seems impossible.
It’s like the store never ends.
I keep calling out her name, “Brenda!”
but there’s no response.
Just my own voice bouncing off the flat white
surface of the rows of MUSKEN wardrobes.
I was such a jerk.
I always do that, get swept up in the stress
when we go furniture shopping.
I told myself I wouldn’t this time, but
like clockwork, I got overwhelmed by the vast
aisles, the myriad of options, the hard-to-pronounce
names.
I was impatient.
I told her to go look at throw pillows on
her own, because I was sick of getting sidetracked.
She loved throw pillows.
No, no.
I can’t let myself do that, it hasn’t
been that long.
She’s got to be here somewhere.
I can’t let the last time we spoke be a
fight about living room décor.
Day Two
So, it’s my second day lost in Ikea.
Can’t believe I just wrote that.
Also, I’m not entirely sure how many days
it’s been.
There are no windows here, I can’t see when
the sun’s up and when it’s down.
The lights turn off sometimes, and I think
that’s meant to indicate night?
But I really can’t be sure.
The clock on my phone is stuck at 3:22 PM,
the exact time we entered the store.
I guess I should say, I’ve slept once since
being here.
Managed to camp out on a JESSHEIM futon mattress.
It wasn’t the most comfortable, but I’ve
definitely had worse.
This place reminds me of the Island of the
Lotus Eaters in The Odyssey.
I can’t tell how much time is passing.
Days and nights don’t really exist here.
Speaking of eating, I wish I had some food
right about now.
Brenda always has granola bars in her purse,
she’s ready for anything.
I’ve always admired that about her.
I had a piece of gum in my pocket but I think
it lost its flavor ages ago.
Nothing to eat, no one to talk to…I haven’t
seen an employee, another customer, not a
single living soul.
I don’t have any signal, but my phone still
has battery, and my step counter app says
I’ve walked thirty miles.
Thirty.
Miles.
And still not one friendly face, no exit sign…
I just had the most horrible thought, as I
sit here on this pile of STOENSE scribbling
in this notebook.
What if I’m dead?
What if I died on the store floor, keeled
over from a heart attack or a stroke or something,
and this is my eternal resting place?
I know I wasn’t perfect, I could have done
more charity work, volunteered at soup kitchens,
and helped more old ladies cross the street,
but I didn’t think I’d wind up in Hell.
The philosopher Jean-Paul Sartre once wrote,
“Hell is other people.”
But I’d like to respectfully disagree with
Monsieur Sartre.
Hell is an endless, vacant Ikea.
Day Three
So it turns out that I’m not alone here.
Not exactly.
I still haven’t seen another human being,
but I did see something else.
While I was trying to sleep, nestled in a
makeshift bed of FJÄDRAR cushion covers
and kept awake by the gnawing growl of my
empty stomach, I heard a shuffling sound several
feet away.
Footsteps.
I sat up, eyes darting around for the source
of the sound.
Could it be Brenda?
Or some other hapless soul sucked into this
prison with me?
I spotted the silhouette of a person, wearing
an Ikea employee uniform, that unmistakable
bright yellow shirt - a beacon of hope.
Then it turned around, and I realized this
was no ordinary salesperson.
Their face was smooth, featureless, like an
egg.
If an egg was the size of a human head, and
perched on top of a seven-foot frame.
Once I noticed its face, or lack thereof,
I took in the rest of the creature’s nightmarish
form.
Its proportions were all off; short, stubby
legs beneath a distended torso that stretched
into long, long arms that dragged along the
ground as it walked.
Its hands were massive, with tapered fingers
perfect for grabbing anyone who gets too close.
Well, there was no way in hell I was falling
asleep with that thing roaming around, so
I got moving and tried to sneak my way past
it.
I thought I was in the clear when suddenly…
”Excuse me, sir?”
A voice came from the direction of the monster,
even though it had no mouth to speak with.
“The store is closed.
You need to vacate the premises.”
It spoke in a pleasant tone, polite.
A true “customer service” voice.
But when I turned, it was ripping its way
through the maze of furniture toward me like
it wanted to tear me limb from limb.
I haven’t done much running since my high
school track and field days, but I turned
and booked it as fast as I could.
Didn’t matter that it was dark, didn’t
matter that I could trip at any second and
land face-first on a lamp or the sharp corner
of a table.
I had to get as far away from that thing as
possible before I found out first-hand what
exactly it did to trespassers.
But my stamina isn’t what it used to be,
and I could feel exhaustion catching up to
me.
I could hear the thundering of the creature’s
footsteps as it gave chase, and I knew my
heart couldn’t keep this up too much longer.
So I did what I used to do when I was a kid
and the big neighbor boys tried to beat the
crap out of me on my walk home: I hid.
I yanked open the doors to a wardrobe and
I stuffed myself in, holding the doors closed
from the inside.
I could hear a scrabbling sound against the
door, the scraping and scratching of the staff
monster trying to get at me through the wood.
But thank the Swedes for their fine engineering,
because that wood just would not give.
After what felt like an eternity, the assault
on the door stopped, and I could hear the
creature shuffling away, off to another section
of the massive store.
I stayed there in the pitch dark for a long
time, slowing my breathing down and trying
to get my heart to climb back down from my
throat.
What was that thing?
Did it live here?
Where did its voice come from?
How did it know I was here?
The questions bounced around my mind, and
I knew I might never find the answers.
I had guessed before that this was no ordinary
Ikea, the endless rows of aisles and total
lack of any human beings had been a pretty
good clue.
But now I knew for sure, I had left my own
world behind.
As I drifted off to sleep, the wardrobe closing
around me like a coffin, my drifting conscious
thoughts were of Brenda; whether she was trapped
in here too, and, on the off chance she was,
if those creatures would get to her before
I could.
After the lights turned back on, and a new
“day” began
I started my walk in search of one thing only:
food.
I had felt the hunger getting to me before,
but after my sprint away from the faceless
monster, my body was nearly limp with exhaustion.
I had to get some calories in me as soon as
possible, or I might not have the strength
to run for my life next time.
It took a few hours of walking, but I eventually
spotted what I was looking for.
There’s only one thing I’ve ever enjoyed
about Ikea, and it’s those beautiful little
meatballs.
As I rounded a corner past a stack of VANILJSTÅNG
plant stands, the heavenly aroma hit me like
the most welcome slap to the face in the world.
There, in front of me, bathed in the warm
glow of the fluorescent lights, was the store
restaurant, and in the center, a trough of
meatballs.
I could see the steam rising up from the little
jewels of meat.
I didn’t care that there was no chef present,
or anyone who could have made them.
I ran to the food and I stuffed my face.
Once my stomach was full of meatballs and
my heart full of new hope, I examined my surroundings.
There were snacks!
Swedish snacks I could bring with me.
I grabbed a KLAMBY canvas bag and began to
fill it with whatever I could grab: cans of
cider, jars of lingonberry jam and mustard,
boxes of muesli, and bags of sour candy, hell,
I even grabbed some of the salty licorice.
When food is this scarce, you don’t look
a gift horse in the mouth, even when its breath
absolutely reeks.
I’m not too sure where I’ll sleep tonight.
Don’t want to be out in the open, in case
more of the staff find me.
I try not to think too long about what might
happen if they catch me next time.
Maybe this is crazy, but I think I’ll build
a fort.
I’ve got plenty of space for it, and plenty
of materials.
I’ll climb up to the top of a tall shelf,
and build a fort up there.
Just have to hope I don’t toss and turn
too much in my sleep, or I might impale myself
on a TÅGARP floor lamp.
Day Four
Something incredible happened.
I built my fort pretty close to the food area
so I’d be able to access it again when I
woke up.
When the lights came on this morning, I saw
someone helping themselves to the meatballs.
It couldn’t be staff, because they’ve
got nowhere to put the food even if they did
eat.
I took a closer look, and it was a person,
an actual human person!
A blonde woman in a blue sweater, loading
up a bag with meatballs and other supplies
just like I had the previous day.
“Hey!”
I called out to her, and my voice felt strange.
Rusty from not talking to anyone for days,
I guess.
She spun around, brandishing a fire axe.
Right, she probably thought I was a staff
member preparing to attack.
I waved my arms to draw attention to my face,
its eyes, nose, and mouth, to make it clear
I wasn’t one of them.
“Sorry!
Sorry, I’m human!
Hello!”
Her posture relaxed, and she motioned for
me to come down and speak to her.
She introduced herself as Gloria, and explained
that she was part of a community of other
humans who had built a town in the Checkout
department.
They had set up lights, beds, and, most importantly,
a gate to keep the staff out at night.
“How long have you been here?”
she asked me, as we made our way toward Checkouts
together.
“Four days?
I think.”
Her eyes widened, impressed.
“Most people usually don’t make it through
that many nights alone in here.
The staff gets to them first.”
I shuddered at her words, and my thoughts
turned once again to Brenda.
I asked Gloria if she’d seen my wife at
all, if she’d made it to Checkouts before
me.
She shook her head sadly.
“I came in with my sister.”
She told me.
“I haven’t seen her since.”
“And how long have you been here?”
I asked.
Gloria sighed, and patted me on the back before
speaking again, “About a year.”
We were silent the rest of the walk, and by
the time we reached the gates of Checkouts,
the lights were turning off for the night.
“Quick, we need to get inside.”
Gloria ushered me through the gates and followed
behind.
I was about to question her urgency when suddenly
two faceless horrors lurched from the shadows.
These two staff members were smaller than
the one I’d seen before, maybe four feet
tall.
They had the same long arms though, and they
were reaching for us as they ran at the gate
with primal speed.
They threw their bodies against it, arms stretching
toward me and Gloria.
I screamed, jumping back.
Gloria just watched them, stone-faced, waiting
to see if this would be the night they actually
broke through.
After a while, the staff gave up and stumbled
away, and I turned to take in the town of
Checkouts.
I never thought I’d be so thrilled to see
a collection of beds, lamps, and strangers.
So many people, when I had worried I’d never
see another person again!
There are around 40 people in total, though
I haven’t met everyone yet.
Some folks were already sleeping when I got
there or keeping to themselves.
The people I did meet nearly knocked me out
with their kindness.
They fed me, gave me water, a bed to sleep
in, and a set of clean clothes one of them
had fashioned out of sheets.
They’re not exactly stylish but I’d take
anything over the t-shirt and slacks I’ve
been sleeping and sweating in for days.
I think I could be okay here, at least for
a little while.
At the very least, I think I’ll get a good
night’s sleep for once.
Day 11
So I’ve been here at Checkouts for about
a week now, and as bizarre as it feels to
say this, I think I’m starting to settle
in.
Being around other people keeps me sane.
Without that endless stretch of silence, there’s
less space for my mind to wander to the worst
possibilities.
John, one of the men here, had a phone charger
with him, and I was able to get mine juiced
up again.
There’s still no signal, but I had a few
movies saved, and plenty of podcasts.
I’ve been listening to a true crime show
with some of the other people here, distracting
ourselves from our own horror with the tale
of somebody else’s.
We gather around, break into the rations we
gathered during the day, and even crack open
some of the cider, while we listen to the
silky-voiced narrator take us through the
story of bloody murder in a small town.
It’s kind of like summer camp.
You know, without the nature, or the camp
counselors, or the possibility of it ever
ending.
I’ve been asking around about Brenda, describing
her, seeing if anyone’s spotted her, dead
or alive.
No one has.
Gloria said that maybe Brenda never made it
to where we are, maybe she found the exit
a long time ago and she’s somewhere in the
real world waiting for me to come back.
That’s what she thinks happened to her sister.
It’s coming up on the one-year anniversary
of her getting trapped inside, and she told
me a secret.
She’s planning to try and escape.
She’s spotted exit signs before, and tracked
them across the store.
They seem to move around, though, shifting
from one place to another when no one is watching.
But she’s figured out a pattern, and she’s
going to put it to the test.
She’s leaving next week, she wanted to tell
me.
She’s a nice lady, I hope she makes it.
Day 18
I woke up to the sounds of screaming.
I rushed to the gate to see what was going
on, and I saw John walking back from his supply
run, cradling something in his arms.
I couldn’t make it out, but it was limp,
pale, and dripping red.
As he got closer, I saw a head of blonde hair,
and my stomach dropped.
Gloria.
She had snuck out while everyone was asleep,
didn’t want to say goodbyes, and had tried
to find her way out.
The Staff had found her first.
She was dead by the time John spotted her,
lying on the ground, a crimson smear across
the tile signaling where the staff had dragged
her.
They packed her up into a box as a kind of
burial, we all said a few words, and then
two of the men took the box away.
They had to put it somewhere far away from
the town…before it started to smell.
I can’t sleep, I can’t stop thinking about
Gloria and what happened to her.
She seemed so sure…so confident.
I’ve been looking through her things, what
she had left by her bed.
There isn’t much, but there’s a notebook
like mine.
She wrote her plan in here, everything she
noticed about the exit signs, the Staff’s
behavioral patterns…I know it didn’t work
out for her, but there’s something here.
No one’s spotted Brenda yet.
I don’t think she’s in here with me.
I think, somehow, she got free.
If she’s out there waiting for me, I can’t
spend one more night here.
I won’t.
I’m going to go for it.
I’m finding the exit tonight.
Whether that’s the door out of this place
or the sweet release of death, I guess we’ll
just have to wait and see.
Either way, I’ll be out of this Scandinavian
modernist hellhole once and for all.
Now go check out “SCP-3008 - Trapped in
IKEA” and “How To Actually Beat SCP-3008
The Infinite Ikea” for more on the deadliest
furniture store around!